today's the biggest game of the season
and the giants control their own destiny
and that is a fact on the hill tonight
for the giants will be the veteran
johnny quito in his 13th year at the big
league level lifetime against the padres
8-5 with a
368 era
that's right i'm going to miss and
that's how this game gets started it'll
be tatis following grisham always fun to
watch johnny cueto pitch triple shimmy
and it's outside it's three and two
there might have been a new one teddy i
i don't know if i've seen that many
shimmies no
before a pitch he could have gone into a
catonic state there i mean he he gets up
on that back leg and you don't know what
he's gonna do and the payoff and he got
him
shadow hitting 306 16 home runs 47 runs
batted in
and hits this one on the ground to
crawford
and crawford will go to belt and that'll
end the inning
let's take a look at the numbers for
zach davies 27 year old he's having one
heck of a year making his 12th start the
final tune-up for the right-hander
but recently not a lot of support for
zach early on he was getting ton of love
just received two combined runs of
support his last two outings nobody's
had more success in this staff than he
has and there's a broken back layer into
shallow right field so dickerson first
ball swinging gets the first hit of the
game here's donovan solano here's a
payoff pitch by zach swing at a miss
strike three great change up great
change up solano thinking he's going to
get a fastball there no no no so the
giants have two men on it here's wilmer
flores who homered in each game of the
doubleheader
the 2-2 is a ground ball on the right
side zach you're out of it man grab by
morgan shuffling to the left
o2 pitch coming up to hosmer
and hosmer shoots this one on one hob to
solano
see the
mark on the back of
hosmer's jersey the kansas city royals
every player put that pine tar on the
back of their back in honor of alex
gordon who announced his retirement from
baseball so hosmer and gordon long time
teammates that's pretty cool brandon
crawford why not nobody on you see the
shift against brandon crawford who had a
home run in game one of the doubleheader
that is a strikeout number two for
davies and here is mauricio dubois
payoff to dubai has swung on and missed
a change up and back-to-back strikeouts
for davies he's got it going
tatis jr leads off for the padres here
against johnny cuedo first pitch
sitting on the first pitch fastball oh
bye now his third this season here at
oracle park couple of hernando puts the
padres in front and it's the first pitch
breaking ball and it is a hangar you
hanging oh and he will bang he give that
kid a piece of cake the big cake
annie also hacking and he rips one into
left field for a base hit nobody out
runner at first here is eric hosburn
nice looking swing from haws he strips
he's not going to get there
had a shot at second note
and here is mitch moreland and runners
at first and third machado at third fam
at first and he rips that one into right
field for a base hit rbi single mitch
moreland andy machado checks in tommy
pham on his way to third and the padres
add another here at the top of the
fourth inning
austin nola with the runners at the
corners
and now nola sends that one into center
field dubon there but that'll get a run
home tommy fan on his way plate work
three to nothing padres here in the
fourth giants are right at that point
where they need to start putting
something together
there's a line drive to right field and
a base hit nice approach
heinemann a switch hitter batting
left-handed and it hit him giants will
have two aboard and one inning for the
first time since the first and yesterday
will come up
runners going and the throw down to
third is gunned perfectly done by nola
and machado dovan out stamen trying to
get through two scoreless frames and
that is
strike three the giants run themselves
out of a potential inning two down
nobody on and tommy pham will come up
here's the pitch line drive diving to
third is longoria to make a backhanded
catch
longoria diving toward the foul line
fully extended
and he took one away from tommy pham
nicely done juanita the new pitcher for
gabe kepler is coming into his 25th game
one-on-one with a 3-5-1 er a solid
season
swinging a high fly ball to left toward
the line in to shallow left and toward
the line comes dickerson nola who is
halfway the second immediately turns
around it goes back to first so peralta
retires cronenworth on one pitch
two down in the inning and jurickson
profile to come up
right to belt who's going to knock it
down he will backhand it to peralta and
that'll end the inning slater to pitch
hit giants have
not had a single leadoff man reach base
in the game tonight and the giants will
take a walk that's a rally strumsky is
one for three
ski is going to flip one into left field
a base hit so that is going to get the
time run to the plate and it's going to
be darren rough jazz have some action
here with nobody out and he walked him
easy take so three nice at bats in a row
the giants got it going faces loaded
nobody out here's solano solano's oh for
three
got him solano strikes out here's belt
belt hits one right back to where it
came from that's one
and belt beats it out so the giants are
on the board and they keep the inning
alive the giants trailing three to one
here in the eighth inning the possible
tying runs are on base tavilla is out
there and he's gonna face wilmer flores
on the ground and a base hit to left
field coming into score is just belt
goes to second it's three to two second
hit of the game for hosmer and here
comes tommy pham spam smokes this one
out to left field and over rough and
over the fence a two-run homer tommy
pham continues to heat up as the
calendar gets ready to turn to october
and the padres get both runs right back
in the top of the ninth inning five to
two san diego so back to a three-run
lead just like that another gut punch
for the giants
and now mitch moreland strokes one out
towards deep right center field this one
is gonna go
padres go back to back again
and mitch moreland leaves the yard here
in the ninth inning his tenth overall
and his second as a padre for the sixth
time this year the padres hit
back-to-back homers trevor rosenthal
comes on in a non-save situation here's
joey bart 3-2 pitch swinging to miss he
struck him out of fastball on the
outside at 99 for the giants and now
they are back under 500 with one game
remaining